so that was the first time you played
bullet
over the board oh like
in my life or recently recently
it's been it's been a while i played one
game
with rey bullets on this wildly chess
this is probably the last time um
but wobbly so one one rule before we
start
if you make a move and the piece like
wobbles over to another square
and it's illegal and you hit your car
you lose okay and if the piece like
falls off
the board where it's illegal you also
lose so you have to like you have to
play cleanly
okay there's no hitting the clock like
making a move
so hitting the clock and then adjusting
but if it
uh moves and i didn't hit the clock i
can still adjust right
okay so just clean play bullets clean
professional ethical chess we don't want
messiness
okay okay um okay
i guess and then we'll play a couple of
games okay so good luck yeah good luck
ooh tricky tricky oh well you gotta try
you gotta try
oh no you're a knight i don't know your
f pawn
oh no my f1 oh no
all your pieces are now falling except
maybe not
maybe maybe
accidental tactics
nothing like them nothing like them
so much more difficult to bullet than
this
oh man okay oh
okay
ah this is my rook
all right okay
attack attack stop it
don't hurt me attack
okay
oh no my king oh no my king
oh that was close i even this position
is
uh quite picturesque who's better in
this final
like i think it feels
i think i might be slightly better but
i would go even how about you
uh yeah like these pawns are guaranteed
to trigger
you you probably have more of winning
chances yeah but
once you trade please don't you go back
like comes back in the night my apon
survives
and uh it's tricky i think i have
winning chance like in a practical game
i might be better
yeah but uh i think objectively once you
trade you will be able to
like sacrifice on c3 and
that's true yeah i can probably bail out
yeah i think yeah
you're going to bail out my king is just
too good which
also made a much longer position
one thing it was smart strategy for you
in the opening to
move the a pawn and bullet because you
you made quick moves
yeah and game two you were just playing
closer to the block this
bullet also the strategy king strategy
of moving in wasn't too bad i think
because uh but again i have to
get uh rhythm of which piece is easier
to move
right so maybe even though it wasn't too
bad to bring the king in and closer to
that flock
uh the fact that my king might be the
heaviest piece
i feel like it just takes more hand-eye
coordination too because when the pieces
are wobbling you really have to like
pick it up cleanly
yeah and place it cleanly yeah let's do
one more
sure i'll be black now one
one more rule um try not to slam
the pieces okay because the wood devil i
don't know how
good quality the wood is yeah so moves
should be relatively quiet
relatively quiet i realized that like we
were both making like loudest now yes
okay so i try and play quickly
but also quietly and cleanly
does that make sense
life quality is going down very fast
yeah i just want to be respectful yeah i
will try to be as respectful as
i possibly can yeah okay all right uh
good luck yeah good luck and you can
start
oh okay
so
oh
not bad i couldn't really put it down
otherwise
so
[Music]
that's your bishop hopefully
hopefully it's my bishop
oh you're coming after me oh you think
okay
oh you know what i'm doing it's not fair
it's not fair
okay ah might look
okay every blunder as a sacrifice
it could be it could be because knight
that wasn't intentional like when you
took when you took here i didn't see my
rook was hanging yeah green f5 was
in an intentional brilliancy yeah
because i think
uh i have no like if i move while you
take oh
you take and queen h2 mate um
the lights are tricky with the queen
yeah
oh but i have so i i could have gone for
mate bishop f8 and rook h1
that's hard to see yeah it's hard
especially when everything's wobbling
yeah as so queen here here yeah i could
go
bishop affair king there check
no i can go bishop e7 king here check
check and checkmate
i'm gonna have to see the video replay
and then put it into now
okay but yeah if this goes on youtube
people in the comments can
let us know of course just
talking yeah so as far as yeah i think
that
yeah that's it's made because also if
you
check i can take with the rock king
takes and queen h8
oh yeah
so it was poisoned but this one just
is poison that's true yeah anyway okay
this goes on youtube
thanks for watching you can check out
chessweeb on his twitch and youtube
channel
be sure to like and subscribe and we'll
see you in the next video